what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back to watch two
episodes of the bad batch two by nine
and two by ten because someone was a
little under the weather last week
Michael the Tesla follow him friends
multi-house dot IO
find out what that stands for
I think IO stands for Indian Ocean it's
really yeah you learn a lot here when
you watch episodes of the bad backs yeah
no we come with we come with facts
evidence and other critical details with
that in mind you guys again it gives you
guess goodness
and then I feel like there's something
oh yeah full length to action watch
along as we sing with your own copy for
the bad batch available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page over
there we cover several things
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch Longs included you ready to pick
up where we left off
that's please stand clear of the closing
doors
foreign
[Music]
the show maintains its beauty these set
pieces are just gorgeous
[Music]
this is gonna be a really fun episode
however in its raw State the mineral is
highly combustible like a primed thermal
detonator
[Music]
deja's about to say sounds dangerous I
have the same intellect as wrecker
you sure do Greg ah man
I'm so excited for the Fallout show
right now yeah
oh
problem
yeah that big freaking storm
wrecker to assist with operations inside
the mine I'll be the lookout
in the area keep your eyes peeled in
Commerce if you see anyone freaking Sid
greatest character in Star Wars history
[Music]
oh wait that's a character I don't know
looks like Sid was deceived into
purchasing an already depleted mine keep
scanning
we'll extract whatever we can
looking for unobtainium
[Music]
the ipsium is going to be difficult to
reach the mineral is far too unstable
even the slightest friction around it
can cause a destructive Chain Reaction
that's what she said
I was thinking about Echo it's weird
without him around but you'll get used
to it Omega we require your assistance
on my way
[Music]
I don't like that Omega
Mega okay we don't really see Tech in uh
Omega hang out a lot drill into the
fossilized quads yeah
if the mineral becomes compromised
Vermont during the retreat in reaction
explosion got it
yes that stress the small child with
that job
[Music]
whoa
and that's where the covet vaccine comes
from yeah
[Music]
good
their helmet kind of reminds me a little
bit of Hondos just a little tiny bit
this one's keep asking for it I will I'm
not gonna get it though let's get back
to Old Mattel
what is it hunter
that sounds like a ship
oh no
Grand Theft Starship
no this is not the case there has to be
a way to get
a bet some in the doctor how exactly did
you miss our ship being compromised the
Spaceport approximately 40 clicks south
of here we can acquire transport there
since we do not have access to
long-range Communications without our
ship it is our only option damn that
sucks only Echo was here
it's too long range Echo will pick up
our signal he doesn't care about you he
abandoned you I've abandoned my child
what's that jabbers
oh my God
it's the light
[Music]
no
case if it explodes will all be dead
long live the king
[Music]
that one just comes by and knocks him
oh storm
well that would certainly explain the
Stampede
that's what I'm saying ow
ouch
You Gotta Get It Omega helmet man
mine
oh God
oh God damn it guys
God damn it guys
maybe they'll find treasure of others
yeah they'll finally win
I suppose that's my fault too well
technically yes
the Marauders transponder isn't relaying
a signal it was probably disabled by the
thief who
well then how are we gonna track it what
is that read in the script
we didn't lose Echo he's not with us
we're supposed to be a squad this squad
existed before Echo as a part of it and
it will exist after what is your issue
what's wrong with you Omega
[Music]
honestly I want to be alone yeah
it's actually a good character
development it is I merely stated the
truth she already knows the truth that's
why she's upset
you're a bad father you know that Tech
mind
bad Rock
Tuscan Raiders I'm done with you
I just expect stuff I know
what is Star Wars about an Easter egg
for me to clap at give them time maybe
we'll find a lightsaber show me things I
know
[Music]
oh
she's gonna come out with black eyeliner
oh my God are they the spiders from the
Mandalorian season 2 episode 2.
holy [__] is she fighting treasure
she did oh my God the mines of morya
Bell Rock Me Thrill everywhere
go check on the kid she said she wanted
to be alone she's clearly having a hard
time adjusting to Echo leaving talk to
her very well I wish all three of my
dads talk to me like that you know
sometimes what people say to you might
not be so technical this isn't pod
racing
right racing come on making your [__]
together
Omega
you won't find Echo in there Omega you
are surrounded by enough ipsium that if
not handled correctly could take down
this entire cabin then you better not
distract me teenagers
thought we could use this to blow our
way through the cabin this vein appears
to be much more pure than what we found
in sits mine perhaps you should extract
as much ipsum as you can what a stroke
of good luck I am fully aware you are
capable of the task
grab the empty vials from my sexual
[Music]
you just trying
yeah in his own way
[Music]
how many are left this is the last one
but if you need to get more to avoid the
conversation
[Music]
that's probably the right move for the
show that time they killed her off
oh that's pretty terrifying actually
foreign
[Music]
oh my God they're gonna run to a bunch
of Jawas tick come in
[Music]
Omega do you copy
something's wrong
I think he might be Force sensitive
[Laughter]
looks like I'm getting what I wanted
Tech and Omega episode right
thank you
you think the gungans are down here no
the mon calamari
beautiful
[Applause]
we're still like coming from
surrounded by so much of it
Omega
dive deep down underwater and extract
more for us we only have one fire left
What's it gonna be
[Music]
look
the outside
there is a passageway just beyond this
wall oh we found an alternate way out
you guys didn't retrieve our gear
[Music]
maybe on the way out they'll find some
spice
you will need to carefully scale down
the narrow crevasse and descend into the
aqueduct below you will come upon us
once the Rabbids eject you over the
waterfall but you must not
everything is changing and you don't
even care I'm not sure how I should care
about change it is a fundamental part of
life always happening I
am aware that you miss him but we have
to adapt and move on well that is what
soldiers do well done well done we're a
family aren't we yes of course we are
then why don't you act like it
he just starts bawling
this little goggles fill up with water
yeah
I have to respect that decision I may
process moments and thoughts different
but it does not mean that I feel any
less than you oh I want you to moderate
my YouTube comments
[Laughter]
did somebody grab her hat yes thank you
it's very worried
she already lost her ship and Echo
well done shot
yeah they didn't even need Crosshair
[Music]
Arizona
that is the Spaceport God there does not
appear to be much activity well there
better be some Chow there cause I'm sick
of rat
oh man
Hunters barely got in any time with
Omega I feel like Conor had a lot more
last season they're trying to give
everybody else a chance we came all this
way for nothing I can send out a
long-range transmission with that array
nice
tied up at the moment you'll have to
figure it out yourself all right you are
such a pain in the ass I didn't tell you
to get your ship stolen did I you are
such a pain in the ass all right give me
a few days and I'll see what I can do we
don't have enough rations
I cannot stand said she's such a pain
we'll figure it out like we always do
all right good good attitude but also
God damn Sid I hope it leads to them
being like we need to stop working with
her and join the Rebellion yeah or do
you work for anybody else yeah
I hope the next episode is the next five
days of waiting yeah
uh please roll the credits thank you
well I like the tech and Omega moments
yeah it was it was a nice
um there's some nice writing in there
um honestly I like the episode I think
it just said said it just really threw
me off my uh my game well let's watch
the next one hey let's do it
[Music]
retrieval
nice oh great still in Arizona Arizona
I'm bored I'm hot and I'm starving I
told you to preserve your rations well
I got hungry
it's a really relatable character yeah
especially for all the hot women I'm
doing a trace on his binary reference
code on it yeah don't get your hopes up
kid
did it
look at this [__]
[Music]
is that their hair or feathers Marco
it's Benny
my scouting run took longer than
expected but I found something you're
gonna like lower the shield
whole new civilization here
foreign
[Laughter]
I swiped it from some amateurs poking
around the old mines in the Northern
Territory mine is though traveling ships
like this looks
some kind of attention yeah Betty I
thought you could make some money off it
that's all I swear all right I believe
you
just to be safe this will still put me
in contention for top earner this round
right
we'll have to see Benny will have to see
if they do it better it reminds me of
what's his name from Treasure Planet
never seen it oh Greg
a lot of rations I was scouting out
there for four Road
right you are
the Republic canteen
[Music]
Marco always
yeah
strip the ship of anything useful God
damn it thanks Marco
of course
bet those droids are gonna die in this
episode
cocktroid gets to finally have their
time in the
Limelight I think I found gunky
his signal is 100 kilometers Ace let's
get this thing running and find out
they did it
they are there
I'm reading minimal life forms in his
proximity
in the Subterranean level this place
looks worse than the abandoned Spaceport
we'll do a split approach stay alert it
really feels so small with that Echo
yeah yes I'll have to sell you for parts
because you're useless to me what am I
gonna do with the defective power
drawers shut up Benny Now where's our
ship run
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
screw you Betty let's try that again
where's our ship the one you stole
yesterday that ship Marco has it that is
Benny
take us to it
no way I can't help you go against Mako
you don't know what he's done for me
a little Stockholm syndrome that's nice
but if you get caught you don't know me
I hate him I know he's really annoying
he's probably gonna join the bed
yeah we've stormed tougher strongholds
on that it is one covert infiltration
point from them
looks fun and reliable glad you're also
confident but getting cooked alive
wasn't on my agenda you can go once we
have our ship back
ah boy
like that they're okay with endangering
the life of a child
free fall
[Music]
that's pretty cool well
you were right you said it was unguarded
I love that time
let's kill it
shoot it in the head I'm telling you
you've got a bail before that alert the
others we don't do that
God damn it Benny
[Music]
use the blaster on it huh yeah
I fell into a burning Ring of Fire
you definitely aren't Ipsy of miners
nope
you stole the wrong ship we are treasure
Hunters
[Music]
Vance what she said
this looks like Temple of Doom I agree I
know a shortcut
no tricks
hey I'm not trying to get caught either
I hate this kid I don't trust him I hate
him you didn't ask me what condition
he'd be in how's that my fault relax
it's not a complicated fix it better not
be the hyper just a hype yeah I'm
working my way up but if Marco finds out
I helped you I'll be sent to the mines
so act natural pretty sure you already
work in the mines kid
friends
it's a skill great can we go now not yet
all right all right stand sharp this
Marco guys so repulsive this round's top
owner is Drake
[Music]
you gotta be kidding me are you kidding
me
as for the rest of you rations are low
which means you'll need to work harder
and longer cut
[Music]
oh my God
is this how you treat your employees at
multi-house no comment
play the fifth
I stole a ship and it still didn't make
me the top earner you shouldn't have to
compete for food
that's how it works here
earn our share
but I'll impress Marco
he is brainwashed I think he's gonna
betray them for food
you should just leave with them
don't don't leave him here please I beg
you don't take okay ready
[Music]
sell them to sit please
I don't trust him doesn't seem like he
cares about any of you why don't you
leave is it my home our ship is our home
it's the only one we really have I mean
I was blown up you can have my rations
why would you give this to me for
helping us
thanks
now shoot him till you keep me on the
real rejects
you could have my Cliff bar
the motivator is installed but I still
have to connect the primaries to the
guidance system and adjust the navi
computer in a way Benny's motivator was
also installed Marco appears to be using
his power and means as leverage over his
workers it is a similar tactic used by
the Empire this operation is on a
smaller scale and throughout Corporate
America
[Music]
didn't Bryce and Hughes say they removed
the hyperdrive
hey who are you
hey good morning
are we allowed to do those voices
anymore yeah they need new people the
ipsium he is degraded it is
not according to this
let me see that Marco's a liar
title of top earner is definitely in
your future
you piece of [__] Benny that's all right
he feels bad he's gonna have an uprising
I think you'll reconsider
[Applause]
[Music]
Omega fly you fools
broadcast it to everyone
cared about us at all and I have the
proof right here let me see that oh my
God even he's gonna be on your side
what's going on Marco
how are we toil down in the mines while
you enjoy the spoils
yeah
and thus a union was born
[Music]
[Applause]
teamwork
that takes a lot of freaking trust my
God
that's cool
I could do that yeah take care of all of
them
eat him
oh
[Music]
you're one chance to survive
not a great dude there are things about
this that I do appreciate that they've
added to the writing to have some
criticisms though yeah that's totally
valid but there are some compliments
here's your stuff
all of it
yeah don't you trust me
no
bit of freaking [__] this whole time
you can be whatever you want it's a big
Galaxy you don't have to stay here it's
not so bad and with Mako gone we'll all
be getting an equal share of the profits
now yeah
solve this equally thanks for showing me
the truth hey if you ever need a thief
I owe you oh no every team needs a
burglar I don't want to see Benny ever
again we've seen so many in the Galaxy
like Moco
there are many like us out there as well
and that is something
sure
and so the batch sailed to the Stars
[Music]
okay
wow
all right
all right well uh they seize the means
of production which means I think we
officially saw first ever socialist
Revolution uh in Star Wars uh so that
was exciting
it was the 10th episode I don't know uh
I mean
I'm I'm really conf yeah I'm saying I'm
conflicted as a season because I feel
like we're we're way past the halfway
point
and while for the most part there's been
something like most part it's been
enjoyable like there's no denying that
most part it's been enjoyable
uh filler is not the right word because
there are episodes like this which maybe
are not
these two episodes that maybe don't go
in full service of like the big story of
words leading to but you get some nice
character nuances you get some nice
character development like yeah I like
the stuff with
Tech learning a little bit more about
emotions and how to be because you don't
really you don't get much Tech and Omega
together so you got some of that Tech
and Omega bonding with one another which
I like I even appreciate some of the
writing when it came to this
um oppressive force with Mako and the
way the children are where they do trust
their kids and even when Marco's about
to die they don't just like Devour the
guy or let her like let him burn you
know there's still that moment of of um
inner conflict of no take my hand
survive like they still
they still have a care for him because
they're like you said earlier like looks
like Stockholm syndrome situation you
know that it wouldn't just go away
that's like kind of a surprisingly
realistic Nuance of abuse that they
implemented into them so like I enjoyed
that uh it just doesn't
it does feel like there's a lot of
episodes that don't really feel like
it's service of a Grandeur story yeah
and and that's kind of what I'm I'm just
itching for that like you you have that
that first episode early on and the
third episode with Crosshair you got
that two-parter with uh the Clone
um I I'd almost prefer shorter season
with more meaningful episodes yeah uh
and and I I mean I I love that they're
doing character development I love that
they're building out this idea of a
family I just feel like we've spent we
could do that as you as well that's
exactly it it's just it's like a lot of
extra steps uh to get to where we want
to go and you know I think it's
something that in terms of you know the
the episode count it really worked for
Clone Wars
um or you have like a gazillion
characters there's also a gazillion
separate arcs yeah that are all kind of
feeding into each other in different
ways you know know whereas you know
they're really at this point are only
kind of three arcs that I see that
they're following and because they're
jumping between the three I don't feel
like they're doing particularly well at
covering you know uh Crosshair
uh and all the conflict that's going on
there which I think is a really
compelling story uh the Clone resistance
in the form of you know now Echo Cody
and Rex uh and then just the bad batch
itself
um and because we're being drawn in all
these different places I just
um I feel like we're we're missing out
it's not a like I completely agree like
I thought the episode was like really
well written yeah um I appreciate that
it wasn't just caricatured like you know
I mean the exact thing that they're
describing like historically happened is
exactly how that used to work
um and I appreciate the Nuance that's
going into that but
um I just I don't know I wish there was
a little bit more focus and you do get
that itch of like just get to the point
yeah and like I love Star Wars you know
like so I'm I'm of course glad to to to
go on these Adventures see new planet
see all of it I I just feel like you
know the the bad batch as a series would
just benefit from a little bit more
Focus yeah
um and who knows maybe as we reach the
grand conclusion of the season that's
what they're going to deliver on
um I just think it's a shame because I
feel like this show would probably have
a lot more uh traction behind it if
there weren't these episodes that just
like I think throw a lot of people off
well this was the I agree because this
was the first
two-parter I mean they had the first and
second episode but there was some
necessity to that but they had a
two-parter
before that where they aired it the same
night and then then they have this
two-parter which they are you know one
week at a time yeah and the two-parter
prior to this was amazing yeah and they
introduced so many interesting [__] and
it just feels like we completely
sidestepped no I know something where
you got a a tiny yeah you got a couple
of new characters and this new world but
it it's not newish enough where it feels
invigorating it's so refreshing yeah the
Landscapes Arizona and this whole thing
with
the the oppression and these miners
everything about it was like I've seen
yeah other variations already a
thousands iterations like this and like
and I and I appreciate it and I
appreciated it the first 110 times but
now that we're on 111 I'm just I'm
getting a little tired and now that
we're fine like how many episodes are in
the bad 15 yeah 15 16 about that yeah
yeah when you have that many episodes
you're like we don't we don't need this
plot right now I mean like like to the
point where I I wish they would just
after this season if they would like to
continue this model to maybe just be
like okay Clone Wars we're doing a new
animated series clone Rebellion you know
uh and just tell that story rather than
like making us wait two weeks and like
there's nothing wrong with liking this
either yeah like I think this is still
really fun Star Wars and still has its
place I just feel like the show that I
am longing for and craving uh I get
little tiny tidbits here and there just
enough to keep me going
um and it just I don't know it it's uh
uh I hate sounding this harsh because I
still love it it's just uh we are
talking about two different shows uh
that are trying to exist as as one well
I I did you re-watch the bad batch going
into the season I didn't re-watch it no
no I didn't I'm I've been re-watching
clone wars and I'm almost done I'm on
season five
um and it's it's definitely given me a
appreciate a whole new appreciation for
bad batch
um but I also think that it highlights
why bad batch struggles so much in that
this type of of mostly linear story that
they're trying to pursue but with you
know I think writers and the team behind
clone wars that did Anthology uh
storytelling so well it just keeps
colliding in a way that um uh it's it's
driving me a little bonkers well I felt
I felt like the first season even though
there were some episodes that you could
kind of get rid of it still had an
underlying through line where you could
see that there was if I recall correctly
I only watched it once but yeah it was
like this whole story of an escape and
and you and you felt that like they were
constantly on the Run yeah and the batch
was together too I just think but then
there's also the whole thing with cross
hair and everything but but that was
still one conjoined story whereas even
crosshairs Arc as much as it still has
to do with the rest of the bad batch in
this season he's just off on his own
adventure totally you know yeah removed
uh from fighting the bad batch dealing
with the bad batch
um and and I feel like that was
something that the first season had that
that Common Thread and now especially
with Echo gone I mean even just like
looking at him like oh my God there's
only three of them left like yeah
so honestly the storyline with Echo and
and Rex just sounds way more interesting
yeah because it seems like the through
line should be the rise of the Clone
rebellion and you know
um I mean we got other factions of other
Andor and and Rebels deals with the rise
of rebellion so focusing on clone
rebellion and it seemed I keep getting
the feeling like okay it seems like the
batches eventually going to be joining
in on that fight and that's where it's
supposed to go but that that presence of
that storyline seems to completely
disappear when you get episodes like
this instead of sort of reminding you uh
of those things and and that's what I
crave that's what I miss that's what I
miss the most yeah and and part of me
wonders if you know uh maybe this is The
Optimist to me but like at the end of
this season uh well they announce a
separate series that will tell just that
story
um because I I think there's there's
more than an appetite for it yeah um
especially leading into a coming out and
and the next season of the Mandalorian
um because I I definitely think
those stories will have to connect in
some way but like if the bad batch is
you know I mean that that whole last bit
of dialogue was all about how oh outside
of the Empire there's all these other
bad guys that need to be dealt with if
that's going to be the pure focus of the
bad batch then
please give us a separate show
so that we can also follow that other
story not to say that I won't watch and
love this
um but I just I feel like that's what uh
uh I'm not I'm not mad at the bad batch
I'm just I'm mad that I want another
show that the bad batch keeps teasing me
yeah I mean if you're gonna do this many
episodes you just can't have too much of
it's fine yeah you know there's a lot of
fine
in here with intermittent okay this one
was surprisingly great yeah well it's
just like we've said like what was it
episode two when we were on Serrano like
Dooku's old planet three um three and I
I we've we've seen this same kind of
like uh things are crappy and we need to
make things better and it's like uh that
is the one thing Star Wars I think
definitively has enough of like well
they're not even really introducing new
like Marco had a good presence about him
for the most part but I I do think that
a lot of times they introduce these new
characters who are not really
that interesting and like I didn't
really care for Benny I like the even
like we liked that episode quite a bit
that a lot of people actually didn't
like the riot racing episode like we
really enjoyed that it was fun and and
as an inventive yeah yeah and there were
characters that I was really I like the
Droid the Droid was uh was so funny at
Ben Schwartz uh I thought that would
have led into more Sid being not such
she didn't even do it like no they had
the Cliffhanger did the opposite of
something yeah they had said Sid hung up
on them which also raises the question
that they let Sid know that they don't
need to get picked up I know like they
had the Cliffhanger like okay I guess
Sid is Gonna Come Around even though
it's just I'm sick of that beat with Sid
as well yeah of like I send you on a
mission it goes wrong no my problem like
God damn these guys have like none of
these guys are just bad for you smart
too like they're not idiots they know
that they're getting a raw deal like the
popcorn that they that Sid has it's just
it unless it's good enough to keep them
coming back
um no I don't know it's a you know like
Omega said it's a big Galaxy out there
you could do anything you want so why
the hell are we still going back to this
yeah you know so
I don't know I don't know and you know I
I think it you can you can have those
silly characters and I think there's so
many instances of that being done right
like Hondo especially like re-watching
the Clone Wars a ridiculous silly
character but at least like they have
some redeeming qualities I haven't found
any yet regarding Sid all all that I
feel is just like
this is the biggest waste of a
I mean it
you need a character if you're gonna
have somebody sending you on ridiculous
missions and all that that at least
you're excited to come back to that has
an air of mystery or interest that feeds
into a larger narrative and like they
teased a little bit of it during the
riot racing
um but we haven't gotten any anything
for that sense a lot of times it seems
like they're teasing something that's
going to be bigger to come and it
doesn't really yeah and like the best
episodes are the ones that are not bad
batch focused like Hunter is not
interesting this season he's just not
Hunter plain and simple yeah he's not
interesting and I I really feel like
he's take I understand wanting to
elevate your other characters and give I
I I love Tech I do I think Tech's a
great character and
Omega is learning things that other
character like Omega needs to learn [__]
even though she's learning things that a
lot of other characters we've seen that
are already so yeah she's learning yeah
but yeah and and listen I I'm a I'm a
firm believer that like Star Wars
belongs to all of us yeah and that like
it's an entry point
for you know there's a whole new
generation of fans that this might be
the first piece of Star Wars content and
Omega is a great character to follow in
the same way that Ezra you know I mean I
think a lot of complaints about uh Omega
we got the same ones about Ezra and Ezra
grew up into a character that I really
really appreciated and
um and honestly I really haven't found
Omega that annoying I found the other
adult characters more annoying in the
show
um so you know I I don't I don't have
issues with that I just
I think the problem is is they show us
that they're capable of of doing better
um and then instead of continuing to
deliver on their strengths uh instead
they they just continuously fall back on
um their weaknesses I mean this I
thought this I I weirdly
like the the plot of the second episode
10 episode 10. it was more interesting
because you got more [__] going on and
you got this bad guy so that's more
interesting but the emotion of the first
episode was Stronger to me of the grief
and the contemplation of how to handle
the situation with tech and and Omega
and it's like I felt like that should
have been the through line yeah well it
I don't feel like we really got any
closure on that other than like Tech
briefly kind of opened up but there
really wasn't any resolution no
you know and and I understand you're not
going to get that full resolution but
still like
um
I don't know I I
obviously they're gonna give us some
kind of reward uh for the Clone
Rebellion at the end of the season so
you know the next couple episodes are
probably going to be action-packed but
for for a two-parter which historically
I think all their two parties have been
so strong
um this was this was weak and to think
like you're gonna make us wait two weeks
after that epic yeah uh is I don't know
it doesn't know how to ride momentum I
think I think as a season it it's it
really struggles with that well I think
it's it's also because of the format too
like you know when when you're talking
about the Mandalorian or you're talking
about you know any the Andor you know
these scripted linear series it is a
Common Thread and even though it's live
action I think that Common Thread can
and should still exist in animation
um and it's not clone wars and I think
it should stop trying to be Clone Wars
well Clone Wars always had the through
line of we're in a war yeah so they
always have that going for it yeah yeah
and but they're in an occupation I mean
they're in a
there is still that that thread in your
opinion and in this show and in this
show and if their desire is to swap to
different povs and tell those separate
stories either commit or don't but this
tease I I haven't been teased this bad
since well you and I
started our friendship yeah so
well I'm not going to play off that too
much uh rats almost got him well what
did you guys think of these episodes I'm
super curious like I said what I like
about it I like about it it's more just
um as a season as a whole I I do I am
I am having an itch and there's too many
episodes where I'm like yeah we can we
don't we didn't really like you could
have easily taken this little element
and then put it into a more meaningful
episode yeah no I'm super curious as as
to what everybody else thought and you
know I and do you guys think we're gonna
get any payoff uh from just the Absurd
treasure hunts and and missions that Sid
is sending us on uh do you remember do
you remember a couple episodes ago where
you laughed at me when I said like maybe
it connects to like Mall
I'm sorry guys uh that was The Optimist
um all right guys well thank you for
being here you can follow Michael and
hey let's end this with a
all right Michael you're gonna help me
out we're gonna give James Pickering a
new Patron James here's how we do the
traditional shout outs for the new
patrons are you ready for it I'm ready
Jay stands for jacuzzi because you make
me feel warm
[Music]
Arizona where this episode of the bad
batch took place m stands for masculine
the kind of quality I like in a man
e stands for equality that now exists in
the Socialist state that has been
established in Arizona and S stands for
Starry Eyes cause that's the kind of
glance you give me my friend
yum James Pickering thanks for being new
to our patreon page I hope you had a
good time you're probably not watching
this show we'd we'd pick you every time
James
uh well super sexy rejects if you want
your name shouted out I would subscribe
to the patreon if you haven't already
the cheers full uh what was that the
cheer is full
you're done sorry your money is no good
[Laughter]
uh well we'll we'll see in the mines
until next week
I'm Greg Alba I'm Michael Tessler and
this is the real
real Rex
[Music]